thank you
okay hello everyone we're here for
wolfen language design review part of
our language completeness and
consistency series
and we've got a few topics here
all right
split by and Gather By
right so we talked about these last time
and about adding an operator form and
then you know this then I
uh
um pointed out that they have a document
why don't you just click on the links
that will take you straight to the
relevant note
okay all right I was I was nervous that
it would go okay
brilliant
well that's pretty stupid
that's just stupid
I I don't think it's completely stupid
right I mean if you have right if you
have a function that's all split by and
you add an optional argument for a
sorting function
then you don't need to special case the
you know when it's not provided right
you can just let us use split in that
case because you're calling split by and
you don't want to special case right
instead of you know adding special case
for the case where no function is
provided
um
you mean you you'll up in the higher in
the pipeline
you have a function which is going to
have a you know deficient argument that
you then want to assume as identity
this is a horrible case this is that we
made a mistake here yeah that doesn't
seem like a realistic thing that would
happen I I understand special casing was
an issue sometimes it doesn't seem like
it would be here
meaning I think we made a mistake too
okay
so I think we should back out this
mistake I think the thing we should do
first
is
I agree we can't do this immediately but
let's at least
for a version let's try and you know
kill that note and generate a warning
message
on a one argument on the one argument
form
okay
and then in a couple of versions we can
we can um
if we didn't hear any no pitchforks
arrived we can uh
back out the mistake I doubt anybody's
used this but we don't know for sure
okay
so let's just think about it for a
second what would be the I mean it would
it would do something heinously wrong if
they had used it
if they had used it and we changed it
right yes
okay so let's deprecate and generate a
message
drat we shouldn't make those kinds of
mistakes be interested go back to the
notes and figure out why we made that
mistake
just out of curiosity somebody could
just do it look at the source control
system and just look
what what what caused that to me I mean
I'd just like to know because I think
it's an obvious mistake
well I mean this is from version seven
he didn't even have operator
so
I don't know that it was an obvious
mistake yes do we not have any operative
forms in version seven
no I don't think so Ben yeah
when did sort by get one
oh much much okay
yeah well okay so we didn't future proof
ourselves properly
um
the
yeah I mean that aspect of working on
split buying Gather By I don't remember
I guess that's why we made that decision
at all
well we should go look at the source
code just just for out of curiosity see
if there's any information what's up do
people know off the top of their head
what an empty list is
right so we do I'll provide the
possibility of
no no no in the second argument right
you can give a list of arguments of
functions in the second argument I would
hope it would do no splitting
yeah that's what I would hope too
okay
okay
all right I'll move to the next point
okay uh so uh open the documentation for
points
uh I have
okay I mean I also have some inline
examples there
um well no I I I'm well I'm starting off
you don't have to open the authoring
page just the documentation report for
Point okay
nobody liked my pun about what's the
point here
never mind
a paint
okay and details and options
so this is uh there's a bit of a camel's
nose issue here uh notice that point
takes two options vertex colors and for
text normals
and this this made a lot of sense
because vertex colorism for text normals
even though points don't have vertices
but you know you can have multi-point
objects and being able to specify colors
using basically the same syntax that you
would for polygon uh made a lot of sense
um which is what I'm illustrating with
my my example on the left
that does something completely different
polygons
well it's not completely different right
the the point is that pure color is sort
of fun it just sort of bleeds in okay
yeah
so
uh in the context of uh uh the Astro uh
developments that we're doing now we're
being asked to support multi-points
where you can specify sizes
this has no analog in uh line or polygon
uh
uh and if one were to look at the
options of points one would say well
maybe vertex sizes is the right thing
although you know now the camel's nose
is all the way into you know the camel
is in the tent with the hump you know
it's uh reminding us that these these
were never vertices to begin with
uh and you know maybe it still makes
sense uh I don't know but then and then
in addition to the naming issue there's
also just a little bit of you know
discussion about uh how this should
actually work
um so I haven't written anything up uh
you know I thought you know giveness the
the the the issue is that the Astro
project wants to use multi-points yes
rather than individual points correct
right because then you're unpacking it
right so you have a thousand stars and
instead of a factory you have a thousand
points okay so this is an implementation
issue at that level
at that level yes
and I mean
don't we have all sorts of packing
stuff that is I mean like for graph and
for other things
uh
I mean I don't quite understand because
if you took it apart
okay you're going to want to operate on
that okay
is a point structure the end of the road
or are you going to want to take it and
operate on it
well I I'm waiting in the context of
Astro or yeah but I think that right the
point structure is is sort of the end of
the road right just just like the way we
write we in geoposition right we you
know we pack in as many points into a
single position as we can because
otherwise right the performance is just
both time and memory is just not
attainable
well I mean look the fact that that's an
issue
it's it's at some level it's like column
oriented versus row oriented storage of
things
it's you know with the data container
framework we will no no no
because
right it's the difference between having
one array and having a gazillion arrays
each with a with a non-array head which
is I and I understand that idea but I
thought the data container was going to
be capable of having just like it can
have quantities of having non-array
heads
in its effectively columns
well even supposing that we're possible
which I I'm not ready to see
um that doesn't change the fact that not
all of these points are the same size
and right now in graphics the only way
you have to change that size is to have
two separate points and have a point
size or absolute Point size in between
them right well or a style wrapper or a
style rapper
so
right so I I don't see how the the
future array helps us in in any way
I mean I mean one could imagine uh
you know a uh uh an array where the
things in the First Column of the array
are head Point size and the thing is in
the second column of the array are head
points
I suppose yeah
um
yeah I mean that's that's not really
buying or something because that's a
weird special structure again and and
and not only that but you know the thing
of head Point size is going to be of
Dimension One and the thing of of had
point is going to be of Dimension One
comma two one comma three or one comma
two depending on your let's make a
couple of comments here so in graph we
have vertex style and vertex colors I'm
vertex size
right graph has that
yeah maybe we should use that for this
okay I don't know anything about vertex
size let me look that up
um if I say random graph
ICS
conflicts with what you want here
why
oh I see because it doesn't have a list
of sizes
it means something else
yeah it's X and Y
vertex size really what no it's a it's a
list of rules of like vertex law goes to
size block
or that's a possible possible
right so you can give sort of a uniform
size but I think if you give a if you
want to specify it's a list of rules
which is yeah no no I understand it's
like one Arrow you know so whoops one
Arrow one
for our one otherwise the defaults
yeah so it's a different setup it's a
sparse array
closer to a sponsori yeah
and my point was you can also have a
list on the right hand side of the rule
that means X and Y
and there's also scaled and nearest
yeah
what's nearest
you do list the string nearest in the
first element
which means what
you you specify
a size relative to the distance to the
nearest vertex
gosh I should have used that more
anyway okay
so
this is a good reason to not have vertex
sizes it's just going to be super
confusing
okay
right and the sort of the other obvious
name is point sizes but given what
points out Point size that's
right so what do we call this thing okay
so my feeling is
okay I'm gonna make a claim my claim is
that if we're really going to do this
that it should be something that is more
like
points and then a list of the
coordinates
you know
and then
optional second argument is that where
you're headed yeah that's kind of where
I was heading but let me just see
something here
I mean I don't like it very much but I
mean I can imagine an optional second
argument that's an association of you
know of lists where each one gives the
you know the point size the point color
whatever type thing
how does that mechanism relate to things
that are used from meshes and so on
um
I don't think I can answer that
Charles is supposed to be here
um what was see everything we did we
make them on call for some reason or is
he just like well yeah let me message
Charles
because I think he's the only person who
could really answer that question
I mean there are situations in which we
so okay will the user ever see this
whatever it is that we produce for this
well I mean it would be preserved in the
input form
um sure but I mean if I look at a graph
for example in input form right I mean
that graph I guarantee is quite
you know nothing nothing like what you
typed in right yeah
I mean I'm pretty unsavory
right I mean I I could imagine users who
wanted to use this
what I I think George Herbert Walker
Bush would want to use this
what for his thousand points of light
oh
um
but no I mean I right I mean I well
certainly actually sander makes a very
interesting point on our live stream
here he says one of the second argument
like disc and circle for point
which raises the interesting question
why are they points not disks
actually Astro Graphics is currently
using disks
so why do you want to use points I mean
disks already have this idea oh do disks
have the idea can you have a multi-disc
but then we have the problem with the
colors we have to insert colors in front
of them one by one
so so the idea is to handle quickly
sizes and colors well but that's because
you have this hack in in um in points of
using vertex colors for colors
I mean if you had the same hack and disk
you could do colors the same way in disk
except well desk isn't the multi disk
right
could it be
um
these ambiguous cases yeah yeah that's
that's the problem is the ambiguities
why I mean you know what it is because
you look at the first argument
and therefore you know what you're
looking for in the second argument
and the second argument is a list is a
pair is that X Y or is that
yeah
primarily for what you are generating
not what a user is typing in
we can deal with putting more wrapping
to disambiguate
well okay so the issue is that
what we really want to do
I mean at some level what we need
is a multi-version of the general
Primitives
I mean so right now we would say
you know Style
blah blah blah comma
Point size whatever it is okay
okay I've got a crazy idea for you
what if
there was a style function inside Style
so you go here you have The Primitives
and what if you had something here
okay the idea is roughly this
whatever it is
oh
it wouldn't be RGB color
what would it be uh it would be
um
oh well that's that's actually the weird
thing is that we've never
uh we've never said exactly what these
options are we never documented exactly
what these options are I mean there's a
arguing colors ahead right so this would
be oh I know but Point size the head as
well but what I'm saying here is
no no because RGB color there isn't an
RGB color option uh is
that there is a point size option
no there isn't Point sizes as far as the
far as far as the front end is concerned
there is
okay that's a different story but but
there is no RGB color option there's an
option for the colors of points the
colors of the uh
that sort of thing you're talking about
a different layer of the design than
this I I I may be but the point being is
that it's it's not RGB color
okay fine fine whatever it doesn't
matter because it's going to get
translated anyway
for the front end okay
so what I'm suggesting here it's not
quite the right setup
is a thing for multi-points for
multi-primitives
that basically is like a data container
for styles
okay that has these packed lists
that say this function
you see what I'm saying I mean this is
this is literally responding to the
let's make a data structure it's similar
to this thing here let's make a data
structure that we can represent
serialize and it's not completely crazy
but it's probably not something you're
going to want to type in
I mean I I guess you're saying it's
basically applying the left hand side of
a rule as a function head to
mapping rather across the values on the
right but look I'm suggesting a thing
that has the same level of relationship
to Graphics that this has to graph which
is you'd never type it in
because I I'm I'm still not
understanding I mean I don't think
you know for this is primarily an output
story isn't it Jose
for me this yes indeed well and and in
terms of you know the user expectations
I agree with you that it's very unlikely
that someone would expect to
successfully read this but uh I do
expect the occasional user to want to
create it create and use it uh because
they have the same kind of problem that
we have which is they want something at
scale to work smoothly
yes and one day I think we'll be able to
do that just with our standard symbolic
Primitives
but I agree this is a good intermediate
but
uh
so I mean
you know look here's a possibility
it's not necessarily beautiful
so we have the notion of directive right
mm-hmm
actually is an idea
okay so right now directive
I could say in my graphics
I believe I can just say something like
directive red
and that's equivalent to just saying red
right the interactive is effectively
flat
right but so now I have the question
what if I had
does directive flattened lists are
inside it
directive doesn't
have any evaluation rules I think
okay but what do we expect this to do
blue
okay
so here's my question what about the
possibility of a multi-directive
which can be given a list
of
things
okay and for for jollies it could
actually allow a multi-argument form in
which you could just say Point size blah
okay a multi-directive
expects to
map across
a a multi-primitive here
and only a multi-primitive rate so not
the equivalent list of
you know Point expanded out
Sandra is asking reasonable question why
doesn't Point size just allow a list of
values and just work
well a I'm not sure it would be possible
um but maybe I mean just in terms of
you know getting the right level of
lists
um
well why well I mean I think that's
basically equivalent to what you just
proposed of you know but instead of
having a multi-directive we have
multiple directives every directive can
be multiplied yeah
I think there's one place where that
will definitely fail
which is a big storm
no I was thinking the circle over
the fact that that works
I wish we did because it was too painful
to always have to be applying RGB color
to things
well but RGB killer 0.4 doesn't mean
anything
it should be pointed out by the way that
directive does this though
does what
uh works either with a list or without
that of course doesn't need to Define
what multi-directive would do but I I'm
just raised that as an issue
I mean I guess the question is
[Music]
Avery is pointing out the director of
Allah says it's equivalent to directive
of the non-list verogs yeah that's
that's what I mean
yeah
so coming back to Steven's Matrix idea
or you know data container idea
is there something there John with you
know the template box support that Jason
with I'm sorry with what again uh Jason
simplet box
support that he just added
to input box
sorry template oh template oh oh
um
that comes back to Steven's style
function sort of but goes even further
well so you could
you could maybe avoid the kernel
overhead so and my understanding is that
there's significant overhead example to
make boxes uh and you could probably use
that to remove the make boxes overhead
um it's unclear to me
uh uh I mean my concern is that you
might have purchased that at the cost of
increased front end overhead uh
template boxes are not as efficient as
they should be yet uh I mean they're
wonderful and we use them all over the
place but but they have a bit of a
scaling problem
okay let's let's zoom out can I well I
just wanted to make sort of two points
which are
um one I mean points uh RGB color of 0.4
doesn't mean anything but certainly Hue
of 0.4 and gray level of 0.4 due
um so I don't think we can do this in
general
um the other is
um do Point size or absolute Point size
take things like scaled or other things
yes some of them do
okay
I mean because one possibility is we
only make Point size a multi-directive
thing
um well and by the way this this raises
the question which we haven't raised yet
which is what is the default thing if
you just gave a list of numbers what is
the default thing is it a point size or
an absolute Point size
you know I I think that look I'm I'm
much more partial to something which is
essentially a packaging mechanism just
like we have things like compressed
graphics
right which are not intended for user
consumption
this to me what Jose needs is a thing
which is for display
it is not you know in a pinch it's
consumable but it's not very consumable
how can I get a compressed graphics
uh really just list plot of a or even a
any regular plot will do it just plot a
sine wave
um
but you'll only see it in the
unformatted so right you won't see it in
the actual boxes
I see yeah this was done by the front
end actually not by the kernel
but don't we transmit things in this
form over wstp and things
uh no over wstp we send the packed array
right that compressed data just
represents a single-packed array and in
which case it's more efficient to just
send the packed array
all right compressed data actually takes
up more data than
that what I'm suggesting is that what we
have
is a thing
let me just think about this for a
second
yeah I mean this would be a direct a
multi-directive
that you could say style of point
of blah blah blah a multi-point comma
multi-directive
blah blah blah and that would know that
it's essentially threading itself
you could even call it threaded
directive it's it's a very obscure thing
credit directive
because that's what it is
it's like threaded isn't it
sort of sort of
and then in here what we would do
I mean I would suggest that we just say
literally Point size
list
he wants another directive you say
threaded directive
I may be threaded directive isn't the
right name
you know Hue comma list
they're all packable
they're all whatever
comments from people
so
sorry go ahead sorry I was going to ask
about colors so colors would take a
matrix right it would be like a list of
of triples yep or put drupals if you
want to add opacity
but it will be it will be a uniform
non-ragged array I mean if you want it
to pack and so on yeah of course
but you're the one generating it so you
have control over that
[Music]
of course you need to make sure you
don't do something silly like uh you
know and an array of reels except for
integer zeros and integer ones you know
don't don't do that
if you do this
on its own right not inside of the style
but right in front of the point
than if you had two multi-points that
would apply individually to each
multi-point just like
red on its own wood
yeah so that was actually the the point
that I was going to bring up is by uh I
mean you know technically no matter how
we do this I could find a way to express
it in style but by having its principal
expression in style uh I'll just point
out that multi-directive would apply
individually to everything in the first
argument which might be a list of things
right and each one
would do that I mean in in
I think
okay so I've got another possibility
and I'm not saying that's fatal I'm just
saying that's a consequence
to me that's sort of a a good thing
right just because I could put like I
said I could pop it out on its own and
then I'd have you know if I had to
separately randomly gener you know two
separately generated points I wouldn't
need to find the multi-points I wouldn't
have to combine them assuming they were
the same shape or you know wanted the
same options
okay I think this is the right kind of
Direction I think what we want to do is
come up with a somewhat obscure
thing which if somebody sees it in the
input form is not horrifying
but it's nevertheless a sort of packing
type construct
that seem reasonable to people
yeah yep
if uh you know it seems reasonable to me
I I would I would put more stake in
John's and Brett's opinions than my own
on this particular detail
so Brett
I mean I'm not opposed
um I mean I have
con implementation concerns but why
don't you guys think it through and you
know to from my point of view this is
going to be primarily
you know like graft it's going to be
something where the input form is not
profoundly embarrassing but it's not
something a user will typically ever see
well so Brett and I can hash this out
and
uh come back with a a refined proposal
in a future instance let me by the way
say why users aren't going to see it and
just make sure that I'm we're on the way
right same wavelength I mean so in the
case of graph the reason reason users
don't see that input form is because
mostly they deal with a graph by just
gulping the whole graph or they have
accesses like Edge list and so on
right
so in the case of Astro graphics
I'm assuming that most of the time users
will deal with it oh I've got a list of
stars
things like that
well the stars are part of the
background it's just that do you want to
say I want to see all the stars Beyond
magnitude 5 or something
and so it may be a thousand two thousand
two thousand
we are supposed to be able to see
several thousand stars
and the whole point is we we just want
to have some way of representing
a packed version of that Graphics
primitive right because then we want to
rotate the sky in a manipulate and we
want it to be fast What I Hear Jose
saying and please correct me if if this
sounds wrong but that is that the the
the the Astro visualization stuff is
like a lot of other visualization
functions that uh you know it does a
bunch of work and boils it down into
fairly basic uh graphical result where
you know the original meanings are are
no longer you you can't go back and
dissect the image and say you know like
like in a plot you can't go back and
dissect the image and say oh this first
line is actually you know uh a plotted
sine wave or something like that exactly
yeah so the stars are generated by Astro
Graphics users will not say give me
these two thousand stars
foreign
but I presume like Geographics the
original input is still in there right
yes but the point is that the original
input doesn't have the list of the 2000
Stars right yes it may have something
saying give me the stars above magnitude
4.
um I mean basically what you're saying
is you want to have
a um
uh
sorry just one second you you want to
have something which is like a
background but you want it to be in in
arbitrary graphics
exactly yes so as the graphics is is
Victoria fundamentally except for the
galactic image that we put sometimes
I mean this could be used also if for
some reason we wanted to represent
cities in the world in Geographics with
different colors and different sizes
because they have different populations
could be used there too
but it's not that common
um
yeah
but but basically all of these things
are background like images that you
happen to want as as uh resolution
independent Graphics right
so I mean maybe we should address that
issue of how to get
essentially a a quotes background image
that is
you know of a large number of elements
anyway I I don't think it matters much
what this is I think you can put it in
some head basically says you know
background image or something or
background graphic
or whatever you want to call it and then
just pack it in with with some you know
a packed Graphics or something
I mean even even I would even consider
something like well we already have
Graphics complex which is maybe not
exactly what you're describing but yeah
I was trying to remember earlier yeah
yeah it's the same sort of thing
exactly exactly so could we not reuse
Graphics complex for this
I mean that sort of comes back to
the original proposal
yeah so I mean Graphics complex is
really about abstract in a way uh
location data not style data
so that that data element in the second
uh in in the second argument that's
that's location see and and you can't
make it be anything else
now you can use those locations as
polygons lines points whatever
but their locations
sorry one second
um
um say it again sorry okay so the second
argument of Graphics complex those are X
Y or XYZ coordinates they they re you
know they can't be things close talking
about oh first sorry yes sorry excuse me
first argument yes uh you know it really
can't be things that like get past the
style directives right no I understand
so Graphics complex itself is not going
to cut it yeah we could add a third
argument called which would be style
data Maybe
uh maybe that doesn't make any sense
[Music]
well I mean Graphics complex already
takes you know vertex colors vertex
you know whatever's
uh yeah I mean we actually it's it's a
bit of a challenge for us to keep on top
of ensuring that Graphics complex with
an arbitrary second argument
can you know work with the the options
that are specified
by the way Sandra is commenting that
multi-point disc and circle will be
welcome anyway and I agree with that
I've really wanted that a bunch of times
fix the radius
disc and circle yes and circle okay
so you want disk and circle to thread
over the first argument that's correct
that seems like a very useful thing I've
I've sort of assumed that works many
times I've been disappointed that it
doesn't
right although I again there's the
there's the bread case service is that
two two circles one the previous five
and one of radius six or is it two
ellipses
no no no no no we're not talking about
the second argument we're just saying
the first argument
we're saying identical circles if you
want different circles you're out of
luck
but you just want many many copies of
the same Circle
right I think he's asking if you have a
list in the second argument so I think
in that case in that case in that case
you're getting a replication of that
list for every Circle
yep so everyone is an ellipse okay so
you so you're not allowed Matrix skew
things in the second argument only in
the first that's correct
that's correct
the first argument will be the only one
that would multi and I do think that's
highly worthwhile and I should have made
that explicit Point myself because I've
run into that issue many times
I I don't know about other our other
Graphics Motors but it seems like a good
thing to be able to do all right so
we've got two things we got that well we
I mean we've been steadily pushing
through all the graphics Primitives
where there were no ambiguities
um but uh yeah well okay so I'm saying
circle is like there's no threaded
there's no multi
there's no multi-multi there's just
multi-positional
yeah yeah we can do that that's
straightforward okay and we should
um okay so you guys need to make some
proposal for this I would recommend just
a very packed object
that is optimized for display and
optimized for use and not don't worry
too much about what it looks like
I mean what it looks like in in um
uh
what the input form is
um
yeah right exactly
okay
um
this one should be much more
straightforward
okay good it'll only take half an hour
okay prototype build
yeah and there is a documentation page a
futurized page that you can open
what's happening here why is this not
opening
[Music]
it's just dog slow
Auto opening the docky tools palette
which was good unbelievably slow
uh maybe that the kernel is crashing if
it's
um okay
all right so create light books
okay yeah I well I I don't know that I
have up-to-date rough page maybe one of
us can share if if we have if you want
to see the actual examples in action
I'm just excited to know what another
this is
so
so the model is create dialogue
okay
and how does this end only with user
only with the user action
how does create dialogue okay
so
but there's no choice that you have like
create dialogue you might expect that
the dialogue would return something to
do with what you picked in the dialogue
it actually doesn't
it create dialogue totally does not do
that
right but something like input
there there are dialogue uh uh uh
functions that do that like like Choice
dialogue does that but uh create
dialogue absolutely does not do that and
that's very intentional
but so create lightbox would again be a
no no information transmission just it's
just a blocker
not by default it could be there's a
proposed option to block the kernel but
it doesn't block it by default
so what happened so it brings up the
light box and then things are singing
and dancing behind it
uh yeah I mean well the kernel well if
you if you if you if the evaluation cue
is non-empty the the kernel will
continue evaluating and if it is uh
empty then it'll just wait until you
dismiss and type something else in
so I mean keep in mind this okay so what
just happened there was it created 10
light boxes
yeah and did you notice that it got
lighter I did yeah
yeah that's funny
um okay but if I if I do this if I say
uh
how do I get through this so I have an
animation going on behind it
um
the cheapest way to get our nation is
uh the answer is yes that would work
yeah like do like
animate sign of uh
I don't know X plus a okay so then then
what I'm doing is I'm saying
I don't understand how I get that as
output oh I see I have that in a
separate thing here I say animate
plot
sine X plus a
a strings by
okay now I create the light box
and mostly I don't it'll just emerge
from the darkness from the Shadows
okay only one level of light box
that's cool I mean I can't use this
thing it's kind of annoying so the the
implementation of this is as an attached
cell that is covering the entire
notebook window uh and
yeah yeah
that would that would be a buglet we can
we can deal with that
that's an escaped pet cockroach as
opposed to God never mind
the um
okay that's cool all right what do we
have to figure out here
so there's a straight collection
yeah okay hold on
where does the label go
in that top area that was emptied so
yeah
you probably should have an option for
that oh there is a lot of the color
yeah I'm wondering if you wanted to be a
bit
lighter or a bit more transparent than
it is just more than one but maybe
that's wrong well and that background
option applies not to the surrounding
gray trousers that's the pop-up
um currently yes
may not be correct
yeah because you've got two different
things that it could apply to I mean
normally background
yeah normally it applies to the content
right so in that sense I think you lose
decision was correct
yeah
but we could use appearance for that
somehow
for what the appearance of the light box
correct of the of the white bits yeah no
wait a minute of the of the of the big
expense of gray or of the uh small thing
in the middle
I was suggesting the small thing in the
middle and then we could repurpose
background to be
the big expanse of Gray
Sandra is currently not sure about the
name lightbox
yeah I agree that that's a it's more
like a blocker I mean
I know that's a name in user
interfaceology
yes that's why we used it
yeah right I I mean I know it's not
capitalized but I was a bit concerned
about the name because it might sound
like a box object which it's not
um what else might it be called does it
called a blocker or something or a um
I mean it is a blocker I mean I mean you
you obsess about these sorts of things
but we didn't obsess about create
dialogue and whether it would be
confused with dialogue sessions
we did think about it we might have
thought about it but we we never said
let's reinvent the world's terminology
because
is a lot more common
right like I never heard the term
lightbox before
dysfunction before you told me about
dysfunction whereas I did yeah and by
the way a light box normally is the kind
of thing you put slides on to to look at
them and things you put transparencies
onto yeah yeah yeah yes I know I've
actually used a light box before yeah
I'm sure so high but I mean but but I
mean but this is I'm sorry to say
what are these slides you talk about
the okay so listen guys but but the fact
is that the use of the term lightbox in
that case is the exact opposite of this
case
correct
which is really bad
well I guess I wouldn't I wouldn't
I wouldn't fully agree with that
statement it is opposite in the sense of
where the lights is but it's not
opposite in the sense of where your eye
is supposed to be
your eye is supposed to be on the thing
sitting on top of you know the
background that's in in in that sense
both light boxes right are the same well
this thing is primarily to be used as a
blocker yes go ahead what are you gonna
say yeah I was going to say dating web
design lightbox is what this is so
I guess for people that are used to web
design this name would make perfect
sense
what else does a web light box normally
do
um
so I mean the main thing is it's a form
of in-page modality
which is to say it's uh I I don't think
this is always true but it's often true
uh that it's it it it's basically
telling you you don't get to do anything
else until you address this interface
yeah I understand
but sometimes that interface contains a
lot of content on it it's not like the
case here where it's a pure blocker
light box
well I mean this of course can contain
arbitrary contents well Canada on the
gray area
not on the gray area but right uh so but
but but but but but the you know the
thing that your eye is supposed to be
focused on is can be of arbitrary size
and and content
what about something a name like
notebook pop-up
it's not just a pop-up
yeah I mean I I really think if you look
at web examples of light boxes it is
it confirms perfectly with what this
function seems to do
which I don't know if this is the origin
of this terminology that the Wikipedia
when when other than the thing for
slides it says light refers to lightbox
as a JavaScript library for displaying
things and dimming out the rest of the
web page I don't know if that's people
yeah if somebody somebody used this to
mean that and it might have been a
non-native English speaker who thought
this looked vaguely similar and you know
God knows if it I don't know have we
used the word foreground for anything
around the color right
I'm not wild about the name lightbox
maybe we can say
I mean if we thought we could go with a
longer name create blocker light box
would get the right meaning potentially
I'm I'm again objecting to the main
blocker but why
because I mean
I know it it carries the wrong
connotations to me especially given
especially given that the default would
be blocking option is false
okay well so I mean it's not like as as
with dialogues
there are two Notions of modality that
we're tracking one is modality with
respect to Kernel evaluation
the other is modality with respect to
Windows
in this case with respect to just the
one window in the case of uh dialog box
it's respect with respect to every
window in the app in the application
exactly right this is what I'm saying
it's it's only it's only blocking one
notebook as opposed to a a true blocker
which would block all notebooks or all
kernel evaluations or both
this this is a curtain on your notebook
no Kendra's commenting shouldn't it be a
wrapper for dialogue input Choice
dialogue Etc
for what to do with the rest of the The
Notebook when this thing comes up
good point
I was gonna say I mean so something that
seems similar to me John which you know
Apple has moved away from
or when they had sheets
you know that I think we're also a per
window thing yes yeah well so I'm
wondering if they are conceptually
similar because because they enforce
modality on a single window yes right so
I'm wondering if this is like window
dialogue
with you know potentially different
appearances as
if Styles change
so can somebody address Sanders point
about why isn't this an option to all of
these things that pop up a modal object
on the window
so
um
okay so if we give
Choice dialogue for example
an option light boxing Arrow true that
might work for Choice dialogue I don't
think it I I
um
for yeah for the various kernel modal
ones I think
it would work but I don't think it would
uh there's uh
for something like create dialogue it's
uh
there's an ambiguity well I there
um because create dialogue actually
um
uh
uh create dialogue
actually returns right Lou
um yeah actually returns The Notebook
object that it created
uh and that gets used I mean by people
who understand create dialogue
um
and there the notebook object in that
case the only notebook object it could
possibly return is
The Notebook that it was created inside
of
right it would be an option that changes
the the structure of The Outpost
I don't understand I don't understand
but this thing why are we making it
isn't it the case that you basically
this light boxing mechanism it's just a
way of blanking the rest of the screen
to highlight some particular you know
dialogue pop-up whatever because
something else might like to know when
it goes away right so it needs to return
yeah I mean I mean so if you you know
just just evaluate the thing that I
threw in chat
notice that a it returns immediately and
B it actually returns something useful
okay now take a look before you go
before you close it look at the output
there's a notebook of GTL which is which
represents that dialogue yes
and
you know that's not just because we were
being completest
that's because sometimes it matters
sure but the what is light but what does
create lightbox returning
the cell object to the the attached cell
and so right you have the reference to
okay so then I'm going to say create I'm
going to say celebrant of that
well that's been destroyed by now so
it's going so what the hell is it
so I don't understand what do you mean
it's been destroyed what do I do you
close this that cell okay okay but so
what I don't like what it says when I've
closed it there but anyway because it
may what would I do with the thing if it
is returned by create lightbox
you could for instance wait three
seconds and then notebook delete it
you know you could have an auto
dismissing
light box
or you could have a behavior which waits
to see if it's been destroyed and takes
an action once it's been destroyed
how do you do that
I I Stephen I think you're laboring
under the notion that this is you know a
a thing which is uh for which the only
use case is sort of uh uh you know shift
enter do something and you're done I
mean
one of the things that we're trying to
do here is we're trying to make it a
fully enabled citizen in the uh you know
in the user interface you know uh
library of components that we have
uh so that uh you know code which may
not be running as a result of shift
enter
and code that may not be running in a
single evaluation but in multiple
evaluations from multiple sources
how do I throw up a light box that
hasn't already been destroyed
um you can uh you can do it and do it in
another notebook uh do uh so you're
saying it's lightbox sort of distance
type thing yeah okay but yeah so create
lightbox you can point create a lightbox
at a notebook object yeah I see it okay
um
right I mean if you want to try it out
right do do evaluation cell uh sorry
evaluation notebook bracket bracket and
one of your notebooks copy out that
notebook objects yeah I get it I realize
how to do that I can see how that would
work
in terms of name
I'm kind of wondering if light boxing
might be a better term than lightbox
oh they all sort of like box Jazz uses
the term overlay
and I was just thinking about notebook
overlay well that was what I that was
what I wrote over here create window
overlay okay
create notebook overlay yeah
um
I would not have quite the level of
Complaint to that name as I do to to
blocker whatever
so create notebook overlay it sounds
like a reasonable thing
and then as the content of the overlay
and to me
and and by the way to be clear I'm I'm
not opposed to the idea of having
options to something like Choice
dialogue uh either uh I it just doesn't
quite work for you know the the
asynchronous case
so what would that option be called
light boxing Arrow true or false
overlay
well if we if we call it overlay here we
need to call it overlaid there too right
so what would we call it
well I think I think it would be
notebook overlay two Falls right there's
overlay on its own means something
well or notebook overlaying
the yeah maybe
um
we have we have modal which means modal
with respect to all windows maybe we
need
a
notebook modal
what is modal an option two
two things like create dialogue
it's just a word modal modal Arrow true
or false yeah
well why not should we have modal Arrow
automatic which means the current window
uh there's
which is something that is slightly
worrying me about that but I'm not able
to articulate it but that would then
deal with the blocking option
for create window of create notebook
overlay
right that is the blocking option
there's a model yeah
blocking with respect to being able to
interact with the notebook not with
respect to Kernel evaluation
isn't that what modal means too
no modal is all about window
availability
about user interaction in Windows
and what's this
what are you pointing at the the
lightbox thing isn't this about model
interaction Windows
yes but not kernel blocking so you use
the word blocking I've maybe there's
some confusion about which is modal a
possible name Okay
no Okay so Choice dialogue for example
is inherently kernel blocking that's
just the design of the function it is
not inherently window blocking but can
be made to do so via option
uh and I guess the The Proposal on the
table then is that uh
uh that
um
it could
um let's see actually does Choice
dialogue take model as an option
it must um
surely it does
uh uh yeah although it seems not to be
strongly documented but
uh yeah so only documents I don't see it
documented at all
yeah that's an absolutely anemic list of
options right well I it there may be a
statement somewhere in here about Choice
dialogue taking the same options as
something else that's that's I'm
allowing for that possibility but I
didn't read all the way through
um
uh but yeah
because in fact if you look at the
options list I mean Choice dialogue
basically takes the same options as as
notebooks
um okay well so this is badly documented
so that's a separate issue but right
yeah
um so
yeah I mean we could do
modal Arrow automatic in that context
and while there are some considerable
implementation problems around that
there's the design problem is uh
less so
um it's not my favorite way of doing
things but sorry but I'm sorry what
would you just say what uh so
uh yeah I'm working down the option of
modal Arrow automatic
assuming that's still on the table
um and what I'm saying is there are
considerable implementation problems
around that but the we might be able to
make it work from a design perspective
though
let's explore so we've got create
notebook overlay
we've got
um notebook overlaying Arrow true or
false
for these other things
and we've got the modal option for
create window create notebook overlay
actually actually okay okay here no
here's what bothers me
um
the uh Choice dialog doesn't have a way
for I knew there was something that was
bugging me Choice dialogue does not have
a way for you to specify a notebook
object
so which notebook object gets blocked I
mean you could say evaluation notebook
that would usually be correct but we
would be basically hard coding that
value in
because trust dialog is a free-floating
dialogue
yeah
which which by default is blocking the
kernel but not the
not the front end but yeah there's
something about this that isn't quite
right I mean I I'm I'm a little
spaced out here to figure this out
I don't think this is quite right I
don't know what the relationship is
between the dialogue boxes and this it
feels like
the kind of thing where this is just
dressing for the dialogue boxes
so I'm well you guys have been talking
I've been
letting my mind wander a little bit
um
and I'm wondering you know is this
something that has to work at the entire
window level
or you know does it make sense to have
something like this for
like cells
that is able to obscure or sell yeah for
some period of time
and I mean yeah
John John I have had this conversation
before yeah yeah I mean so like okay so
I put a link in chat to the puzzling
stack Exchange
because
and so if you go down to the answers
they have these they have this interface
to so that people can answer without
spoiling
the puzzle
right
and then you know to some extent this
feels like a very similar yep type of
thing
I think this thing needs more thought
and I think it's it's being
um
okay let's take a look at the other
items on this agenda this requires more
thought
I'd never seen this before I think it
requires more thought and I think a box
level version of this would be nice
um
and to me it's something which is kind
of like a user interface element just
like you might say
I don't know panel or something right
panel you can put a panel around
anything
so similarly you could put a blocker
around another thing I mean just like
you know to me this is more like a tab
view or something where you say you know
put a tab you around A and B
okay fine and I click it and it does
this and I would say put a you know put
a Blocker in front of put an overlay
you know an overlay Blocker in front of
this thing and then and and to be clear
this I mean the implementation
is just window dressing on attach cell
it's
a lot of window dressing
yeah but it's just window dressing but
what I'm saying is what I'm saying is
the interface that I think will be nice
is something where
to a box like in tab View and just put
it in front of a box and it'll give you
a thing that has this oh clear this
overlay great I cleared it
or alternatively you put it in front of
a cell or in front of a whole
you know notebook
so if I'm understanding correctly you
basically want a part some sort of oh
can't you do that with the obj option
where argument oh only in an incredibly
clergy way with Doms and so on
but this is just a with a Dom with some
kind of Dom handle you could do that
yeah I I don't know what you mean by it
on hand I mean I mean to a cell object
or something like this
um you can't do it in this way this is a
very straightforward way if I could say
um
you know
I mean we've got this concept of an
overlay
what does that do I thought that would
work uh in a list
yeah I mean this is something very
similar
except it doesn't have that clearing
mechanism
right and that's what I would have hoped
would work
well I would say that there's a
difference between this and that and
that this has
right the the tab view had only has an
interior and this has an exterior so
you know how big do you want uh
um
you know right
excuse me
overlay is an elementary thing
uh it's not high level you build things
from overlay you you know using overlay
directly you know to produce an
interesting result is not common what
you do is you build higher level stuff
with it
attached cell is an elementary thing
create lightboxes designed as a higher
level thing but why couldn't I do this
by saying you know create a light box
here instead of having this overlay
where it's just an overlay and it sits
there I have a little button here where
I can clear the overlay
I mean that's a toddler
right right but again why why is that
why is that restricted to the graphics
and not to
uh right if you just had a one argument
thing where it's you're you're uh you
know your your object you know your uh
Blocker of you know disk why is it just
the the rest of the graphics box and not
the whole output cell
I'm sorry what are you saying what right
so you were envisa and visit saying you
know why can't I have a blocker or
whatever we call this function of
Graphics of disk yeah so why does the
overlay only cover that type I don't
know where I understand that's a
different case of look I think there's
more thought required here I think it
should be able to cover multiple levels
of thing and it should be able to be
something where you know I can write
something like this and just have an
xing out button or I can write a version
of this where it covers the whole window
I don't know exactly what those pieces
should be
right but uh well I guess I would say I
mean this sounds like a different
function to me right because you're not
popping up any content right there's
only that you might pop up content
I don't I think it requires this
requires more thought let's not solve
this now
I think we've defined a Direction Let's
more thought I I'm I'm not happy with
that direction uh but I'm not but but
I'm not eager to open up
um you know uh why do we want to
discussion about it because we're
running against up we're running against
some time limits for me here
you mean today yes okay all right well
let's just look at this what is this
so this is uh basically dealing with how
do we show rasters
in the in the front end this is this is
about this is a front-end option effect
you know uh how do we display route and
if you there are some samples uh
examples below
um
what is this for is this is this related
to
that we've seen in in various kinds of
printing and PDF export and so on
um
no
not p no not printing PDF this is uh uh
on screen really
okay so this is the analog of
interpolation order for a curve is that
true
I'm kind of I would write it I would say
it's more like anti-aliasing for your
raster
yeah I mean it's yeah it's basically
choosing an algorithm to generate pixels
to fill in the gaps
so that's the what's the best way to put
it what gaps so so like for instance
that request the fast so the middle
example right that is what like a couple
of pixels tall and three pixels wide but
it's being drawn to a region that is
hundreds of pixels wide and maybe 80
pixels tall so the data for the raster
doesn't fit the destination rectangle so
it has to generate new pixels in order
to be able to fill the rest in
and basically you're just choosing which
algorithm is used there's none so it
gets duplicated you might use like a by
cubic or something yeah this is exactly
like interpolation over I mean this is
like this is like yeah it's I mean I
mean really it's it's resampling yeah
it's resampling
yeah uh so like for instance depending
on who it is and who designed it at the
time
um you know some of the people at
Microsoft like to call this
interpolation mode
um but I mean isn't it exactly the 2D
analog of this
yes
right only on a different axis right
because it's the VA it's right the value
is translated as a color not as a height
but yes yes
which orders can we do
uh well that's that's platform dependent
like it's the operating system that does
it yeah we we are not re we are not
regening it on a per pixel basis
um so like some of them might like on on
Mac you don't get uh the four on the
bottom example there uh I think the last
two on the right are practically
identical
um in visually it seems better to call
it raster interpolation because
otherwise when you say smoothing quality
I'm going to say I want the best I want
High smoothing quality but that's not
really the right thing
for many cases
but I don't really want High smoothing
quality because I actually for many uses
of rastas that's like garbage
well I I'm not attached to the name
smoothing quality at all
um that's that's why this is here what
about restaurant population
uh uh I I I I I think your connection to
interpolation is going to be fairly
unique among anyone who cares about this
didn't weren't you just telling me that
the operating system calls it something
about Microsoft calls it interpolation
mode
um
actually I didn't realize Microsoft used
that name I don't think that's common I
looked it up uh earlier
uh and the Mac I didn't get a chance to
do yet
um let's look at that but but the
Microsoft use of interpolation yeah does
make it you know
canvas the current name comes from
canvas from the HTML spec
um
but like I said I don't like it because
I think that's why moving quality it's
like I want to be smooth High okay but
now it's giving me all kinds of Ripples
and all kinds of weird stuff like this
well I I would suggest that maybe we
want order in here so raster
interculation order or maybe then
suggests that you're actually giving a
number okay which we're not
so yeah I mean let me stress again this
is very much like resampling except
resampling specifies algorithms that are
guaranteed to be run and here we we we
can't guarantee what algorithms the
operating system is going to use
I understand but we don't have I mean
recently will be an image processing
operation on this route well and and you
know that's image processing is
effectively what the OS is doing for us
on our behalf okay yeah I think raster
interpolation is the right name and I
think it should be none as a symbol and
then it should have you know
I don't know none or true
false
full so none should be one thing
true should be whichever one of these
you pick and then we can have these more
fine gradations in the case of an
operating system that supports them but
I would suggest that any of those string
names should be if all else fails make
it be the one that corresponds to true
given that the operating system might
not distinguish them you don't want to
be you know if you sent somebody a thing
that was in high raster interpolation
and it it you know I'm sorry we don't
have that here it's got to not do
something silly
right which I believe is what it
currently does I mean I think on Linux
basically the three pictures to the
right all look the same at least to me
um so okay
okay I I'm I'm up against the wall here
okay see you later John and I will point
out okay
I will point out that we're well past
five o'clock so
um all right okay well let's just see
what this is since we have people who
are waiting for this let's just see what
this is
trade layout
oh God
so is Charles here Charles is uh yes I
am I am here
so the issue is
this
orientation
doesn't have mirror reflection the one
that you're doing here
and this one here with tree layout
right they're the same right
there can right now they're completely
consistent with each other
like TL out is pretty much just calling
you know
the
the three layouts so I mean the issue is
do we want top flipped
whatever that means
top left right
because that's what it is maybe for
maybe for trees but not for graph
right so that's the I don't know I mean
I don't know obviously have a graph
I mean what's the meaning on graph so
for graph when you see orientation so
you just specified where we start for
the root right and we solve it that way
right we don't know
but but you're going to have something I
see you're saying it's pretty arbitrary
which order
the vertices come out in whereas with
the tree there's a definite ordering of
vertices exactly once we don't want to
enforce that
right
so so one question that I don't know the
answer to Is is there a what I mean I
know I can manually calculate all the
coordinates myself but is there an easy
way to flip the orientation if if we
wanted to so for a graph for graph no
well they seem like I mean the three
code back there can just do a graph
embedding you kept recording it and then
you apply it that's what it is
I I asked if there's an easy way not
doing it it doesn't involve explicitly I
don't think it's particularly necessary
but I think for trees
there would be an advantage to
I mean so some coffee out we have a you
know rotation option right we can add
the reflection option to an axis if you
want but
so you can then you know specification
option for what
I think for the graph layout you can put
like orientation there you can see
rotation 90 degree
in addition to orientation yes
I think we have it for all the layout in
principle I think well okay that's fine
so fine but that's easy so it does an
orientation so so the orientation is one
rotation and then it applies the second
rotation on top of that
or is that
no no no no no for for graph layout you
can say you can run the layout and then
you can decide to rotate it so right so
we apply a rotation
I mean just like this
white if I remember correctly we have a
rotation options
exactly but what kind of rotation option
where's the rotation option
oh well I have to look at the
documentation but you can do graphic
outlay you know layer embedding goes to
you know rotation goes to 90 degree
instead of orientation you can change
that to 90 degree I believe
I mean so I should be able to do
instead of orientation or as well as
orientation
um I think if you as well as orientation
we applied oriented the rotation after
that I think
yep you're right
so if you if they need that we can just
also add a reflection option and then
you can specify it at the time so
okay well so it'll be nice to add a
reflection option but the question is
how it's specified in tree
per tree was that left and bottom would
just automatically have a reflection so
that the first element on the top or the
left right so it's done automatically
when they call it right but
no no no no I understand it
yeah right I mean we could imagine
like a list which is either bottom
reversed or we do you know bottom right
bottom left which means like where we
you might you might want to use the
first child
line
hold on you're saying
well we would say top right for example
would mean
the top that is what you put down as the
root
and the first Branch goes to the right
yep
okay so let me add something which I
you know I'm not CL for shock it may
probably happen you know from the top of
my head so there you just have three
I mean four notes right three child
right if you have a thousand of them I
cannot guarantee you that it was the
reverse order or a descent order they
can be flipping I mean it can be any
arbitrary order
right so a reflection by itself is not
even enough
you're saying every level needs to say
which order it goes in
exactly
and even inside to to you know the level
you cannot guarantee that it you know
the order is the reverse order from the
you know the
the vertex list for graph and such no
but you're saying if I look at this and
look at that 5 goes to 10 and 17.
that's an arbitrary choice I don't even
know why it did it the way around it did
it with the 15 1 9 I don't know why that
one didn't go to the left why didn't
that one go to the left
because it wasn't generated as the first
child right random tree
okay okay okay fine but you're saying
that in principle every one of those
branchings
could have a different orientation
right Charles right order they see yes
but uh
well it could have a different order
probably one doesn't want to have a
different orientation like the tree
going you know
yeah I probably won't listen probably
the orientation is top down
all right so the issue is
that at every note right I think if you
just do the reflection right basically
I I
with respect the suggestion I make a
suggestion basically what this is is a
rendering at every node of whether the
children are left to right or right to
left or top to bottom or bottom to top
right so this is another option
that is a node specific option isn't it
just like how much illusion there's
going to be at that node and all kinds
of stuff like that
you know am I missing something
I guess you could
I mean there's that that
I I don't think that's right because you
can specify the order
in
right you specify the order of the
children and now you're going to tell me
that at every node that might be
reversed
only for rendering the ordering as in a
tree wall but then what meaning does the
ordering have if it can be reversed
right right now no it's not reversed for
tree map it's only reversed for the
rendering of the tree yeah I understand
that but then why is this a useful or
interesting thing to do right I then
have no connection right if I know that
you know things here are you know if I
know the first child is on the right or
the first child is on the left and I can
look at that tree and I I know something
about the input form
but if you're telling me that at every
note I can flip then I I know nothing
about what the input form from that
representation
right I think I think the point is that
this would require a mark of this note
is reversed the children of this node
are reversed you're saying okay so look
let's take this thing here right
and if we said this thing here we say if
we say rotate that 90 degrees
okay but if we said of this flip it flip
the whole thing right reflect yep
you're saying that that you claim is a
mere rendering option but it keeps the
Integrity of the tree structure itself
whereas my micro diddling at every tree
node breaks the structure of the tree
itself
right basically I know that it that the
children are in one of two orders at
every level
and and if I care about that I can you
know
right I can
you know I can determine it once and
then I know what where it is well I mean
what we need here
is
okay so right now we have essentially
this rotation thing we could presumably
in the tree layout you could give an
angle and that would be the angle from
the vertical or something just fun
but the issue is do we want to have
you know we've got a tree layout option
here do we want to have the flip around
trees yes I emailed you a notebook
okay
so this was a different idea we had for
using like top comma left for alignment
rather than for
the flipping
and my my thing is the reason we brought
this is every time you do tree layout
goes to left
uh it seems that what you really want is
for the first child to be on top just by
default if you say left
which is the default
no right now if you say tree layout goes
to left the first child is on the bottom
because you rotate 90 degrees this is
wrong that just seems wrong
right and and really if you say tree
layout goes to bottom because you rotate
180 degrees the first child ends up on
the right rather than the left that just
seems wrong seems like a hack I mean it
seems like we just need this option in
um
uh from Charles and Groff and then you
need to just re you know redo the
implementation of this I think it's just
wrong I don't think you need the Micro
Control but I think you do need that
yeah and and so that just be an
inconsistency with graph layout so I
wanted to but right it does but that's
my point is that I mean I don't see the
direct inconsistency I mean there are
two different objects and what I will
expect is that you know three layout
you know should actually take care of it
right you you know
so in the layout you should just get the
result from graph and then adjust it
appropriately
well we can definitely add the option on
graph but I don't mind I don't entirely
agree with that statement right you
might want to to convert your tree to a
graph and suddenly it's
opposite of what you think it will be
you cannot even guarantee that the order
will be respected in half there is no
way
what we do behind the scene we solve an
optimization problem based on some stuff
it's not just a when you say left or
right we are not just rotating
so we just start to solve it with a
constraint that the word node is
somewhere we are not rotating or
reflecting
um
and for me I can see yeah the first
thing is let's fix the default here
because it's wrong for trees now this
question of whether graph of the tree
should be the same way up or not
well graph of a tree completely blows
away the layout anyway exactly
everything is completely different there
is no expectations well here let me do
this in this case so so you're not
preserving the um
is that right I mean or shouldn't you
try and keep the left notice craft chose
a different root node
oh Christ yeah okay well but I shouldn't
it by default keep the layout when you
say graph of a tree
because it can
it can't and it's come back to what you
call the calculus of annotation what we
preserve when we inherit you know we
build it inside graph right between
graph operation should we build the same
for three now so we can build that if if
we really want to preserve all that
definitely we can even preserve the look
why the shape of the the node no but we
don't want to do that I agree with you
it's a calculus annotations question and
it seems like the most natural thing to
do here my first take would be preserve
the the positions of the nodes
right well let's do yeah at least the
road has to be the correct one
definitely
yeah so that one we can fix you see
right I think I think that's what we
should do I think we should try to get
graph of tree
to preserve the positions of the nodes I
think we need an extra option for
flipping in graph layout and then we
need to use that in trees so that when
it's the left node so it's the node at
the left it's really quite important
that the the first uh child goes at the
top really quite important so really
there are many uses of creep which will
be quite useless if you don't do that
you have sense
excuse me
um
uh okay
all right
see you guys
um okay see you guys soon
um okay thanks okay bye